[Musique]
ce serait la plus grande étendue verte
urbaine au pays selon un document obtenu
par radio-canada
la superficie du parc atteindrait 3000
hectares huit fois center parcs quatre
fois le mont royal le parc relierait les
le blizzard au parc-nature du
cap-saint-jacques en passant par le
parc-nature de l'anse-à-l'orme le parc
agricole du bois de la roche et
l'arboretum morgan quelques 1600
nouveaux hectares d'espacés verts
seraient protégés à montréal le parc
inclurait des fermes de production
maraîchère biologique un sentier de
randonnée et un lièvre fluvial mais une
partie du futur parc appartient au
promoteur immobilier de cap nature un
projet de 5500 unités d'habitation
initié sous l'administration tremblay
pendant 14 ans la ville de montréal a
été l'initiateur mais même à ce petit
club le maître d'oeuvre de thau
l'aujourd'hui on vienne nous voir pour
nous dire eh bien vous terrer et les
écologistes qui dit non on veut que vous
voulez conserver mais moi ça fait 14 ans
que la ville me d'idées développé par ce
projet l'ont en effet très justement
l'exode urbain au lieu d'aller dans la
deuxième couronne autour de ces images
dont radio canada a obtenu copie ont été
captées ce printemps dans le secteur où
le développement immobilier serait
construit pour 7 hydro géomorphologue
qui étudie le fonctionnement naturel des
cours d'eau le terrain a toutes les
caractéristiques d'une plaine inondable
les milieux humides ça c'est bien connu
ça sert dépenses effectivement donc d'où
l'importance de les préserver surtout
dans des secteurs fortement urbanisées
comme i autour de montréal où il y en a
très peu
les plusieurs approches dont une qui est
une approche hydro géomorphologiques en
fait qui est bien reconnue
ailleurs dans le monde qui se base en
fait sur les niveaux réellement atteint
par l'eau alors à partir du moment où on
se sert de ça comme une façon de
cartographier les zones inondables c'est
indéniable que les secteurs où on voit
de l'eau ils sont en zone inondable mais
les promoteurs affirment que leur
terrain n'ont jamais été inondé et
disent avoir fait leur propre inspection
il rappelle que leur projet immobilier
conserverait les principaux milieux
humides et que la destruction de plus
petits milieux humides serait compensée
par différentes mesures et surtout
respecte toutes les exigences du
ministère de l'environnement
nous nous sommes rendus dans l'un des
milieux humides qui serait éliminé par
la construction d'habitations
donc on se trouve dans une zone qui est
qualifié de milieux humides vous voyez
ce que ça donne et dans la zone où on
souhaite construire plus de 5000
habitations
le maire de l'arrondissement pierrefonds
roxboro qui était en faveur du
développement immobilier sous
l'administration coderre croit
maintenant que le développement d'un
parc est une bonne idée
tout dépendant ce qu'il en coûtera à la
ville pour compenser les promoteurs
imaginez 360 hectares qu'est ce que ça
représente au niveau de cours je ne sais
pas même si l'analyse était fait pour le
coût associé à l'achat ou
l'expropriation de ces terrains là on
peut pas aller prendre ces terrains lors
qu'ils appartiennent à des promoteurs
avec un droit de construire comme ça
selon ce qu'a appris radio-canada des
négociations sont en cours avec ottawa
pour obtenir 50 millions $ en subvention
pour le projet de parc
c'est sûr que c'est un projet qui
m'interpelle beaucoup vous savez
l'environnement c'est une de nos valeurs
ça correspond je pense à ce que les
montréalais et les montréalaises veulent
alors moi je m'inscris avec la mer et se
plante dans cette vision le plus verte
de montréal d'utiliser même des
infrastructures naturelles pour nous
aider à s'adapter à un changement
climatique aux catastrophes naturelles
alors c'est sûr qu'on va le regarder
avec beaucoup beaucoup d'intérêt la
ville dispose d'outils légaux pour
récupérer ces terrains dont
l'expropriation
mais ce type de processus est souvent
très lent
[Musique]